Hello, and welcome back to Rawkode Academy. I'm
your host, David Flanagan. And today, we have
a another great episode coming of Rawkode Live.
Rawkode Live is the show where we take
a look at open source software within the
cloud native and Kubernetes space, And hopefully show
you enough cool stuff to help simplify your
Kubernetes journey. Because let's face it, this stuff
is mighty hard.
Alright. Remember, we love comments. So if you're
watching this now, feel free to say hello
in the comments section. As we move through
today's episode and we're playing with the technology,
take a moment to ask your questions. Don't
leave them lingering in your mind because you'll
forget. We recommend you take them in as
soon as possible.
Today, we are taking a look at DevSpace
from Loft. It is a tool to help
you ship, build, develop Kubernetes applications faster and
easier. And today's guest today is Leon from
the Loft team. Hey there. How's it going?
Pretty
good. Thanks. It's a beautiful day, surprisingly so.
Yeah. I'm looking forward to the session.
Well, yeah. I mean, you're in Amsterdam. Right?
And I'm in Glasgow. I think we have
quite similar weather patterns, which is usually
Probably. Yeah. Cloudy and rainy and windy. I
don't know. But today's today has been quite
nice here too, actually. That's good.
Okay. So for anyone that
doesn't know you, hasn't spoken to you before,
can you please say hello and give us
a little brief introduction, please?
I would love to. So my name is
Leon.
I'm based in Amsterdam,
and I'm a DevRel for Loft.
And
if you know me from any kind of,
like, social events or something, you probably best
know me as the chief karaoke officer.
So if we ever are at the same
conference,
I promise we we will go to karaoke.
Well, we are going to be at the
same conference. Right? We are. I booked at
the Cube Cuddle already. I'm really looking forward
to it. Yeah. Yeah. We are just, what,
two and a little bit weeks away, two
weeks in a few days.
Yeah.
It's stressful.
But, yeah, I can't wait. So
karaoke
is gonna be awesome.
Okay. Today, we're taking a look at DevSpace.
This is a relatively
new project to me. I wasn't that familiar
about it or I hadn't been aware of
it until a couple of weeks ago. I
think you you tweeted something and you share
something, and I thought, hey. Is this this
looks cool. Like, we need to do something
on this. So can you just tell us,
like, what what what's the TLDR for DevSpace?
Yeah. Sure. So to me, it's easier to
say what it does rather than what it
is.
So, basically, what we're trying to do with
DevSpace is make the development cycles
faster.
So if you're developing
for Kubernetes,
then, you know, there's all kinds of stuff
that you need to be aware of, putting
stuff in a container and everything.
And most developers, they just wanna focus on
developing.
So we're trying to just abstract everything away
from you, make it easy and fast. And
I don't wanna go too deep into details
because I hope we can, you know, like,
learn by doing.
Yeah. I always find this this is one
of these really common questions that I get
all the time, you know, when you go
to conferences and people are doing you know,
we're all in the same journey, but all
at different stages of that journey. And it's
like, yeah, I'm used to developing locally
and I just installed all the tools and
it's fine. And then people move towards containers.
And it's like, okay. Well, I spent up
some Docker containers and I work against it.
But we're now at this stage, I feel
where it's not just I've adopted Kubernetes.
It's I've refactored my monolithic application to half
a dozen or two dozen or 20 services.
I have a Kubernetes cluster. I have service
meshes. I have all these things. How do
I develop locally? And you're like,
good question. You don't. This is this not
a solved thing yet, but there are tools
to make it a little bit easier. And
I this is where DevSpace comes in. Right?
This is the the market. This is the
problem that it really wants to help us
with. So
Yeah. Exactly.
Alright. We have And, again, I just have
to say it's not gonna solve, like, every
problem that you have. Like, I I don't
even know, like, service meshes. And if you
have, like, something that's super distributed,
you might get it to work. I probably
could point you to the people who can
help you with that. But,
yeah, there's, like for now,
this is, like, tackling the most common issues
that people have, not every single one.
Awesome. Oh, hey, Marino. Yeah. There there's quite
a lot of comments going on in the
chat. People are are very excited, so awesome.
Okay. Well, we're gonna take a look at
DevSpace. So let's make sure that screen share
is all up in business.
I guess we could share everybody and see
we were having some I was having some
Kubernetes trouble prior to this going live, and
I couldn't get a cluster to work. Go
figure.
Pretty standard.
Well,
gonna say right now that it's it's you
can use DevSpace locally or on a remote
cluster. It works the same way. So luckily
that we
had some backups.
Yeah. Well, we can definitely try both. Right?
I I've got a mini cube cluster, which
is the one I'm currently looking at right
now. But I do have a SQL cloud
or a SQL cluster that we can switch
to it and maybe try and see what
that remote experience looks like.
We also have the DevSpace website here. So
it's got some nice little
kind of walk throughs here on the homepage,
and we're just gonna kinda get started on
this. I think we'll just send a learn
this by doing, which is my favorite way.
I hope that's okay for you. Yeah. Same.
Of course. Yeah.
Right. That's the first thing you need is
the CLI
that will make things easier. Well, well, actually,
you needed to run it.
Yeah.
We've got a nice graphic. This is a
go over this in a moment. But let's
see if we can get the CLI first.
Yeah. Yeah.
Then Would you should you do you want
me to tell you where to find things,
or do you wanna, like, explore for yourself
a little bit? I kinda prefer exploring, and
I I know you're gonna be sitting there
cringing as I'm like, oh, I don't know
what I'm saying. But
yeah. No. Consider This is excellent because it
this is how we, like, improve our docs,
I think. Exactly. It's a litmus test for
documentation.
It's like, you know, how long is it
gonna take me to find the thing that
I need?
But at least I think I just bridged
all these things. I'm not feeling Yeah. Too
worried about that.
Should be fine. It's not that huge.
But I did see what happened when you
tried to start that mini cube. It
had me a bit worried. Well, you know,
I've I've been at this office space for
a little under a year now. And the
people that provide Internet to the office space,
they they charge extortionate amounts. Like like it
was the nineties and Internet with those new
things. So I told them to go away
and I run off of a five g
router and I have done all year and
it's just been perfect. But I know at
some point, I'm gonna
I'm gonna feel the pain of using a
five g viewer.
Okay. We have DevSpace.
So let's maybe go back to that image
and kinda try and understand what it's doing.
So this is the Yeah. How does it
work? And I see things like Docker, Canico.
I see Registry. I see YAML. So
what what is the the starting point for,
know, taking a project and using DevSpace against
it?
Yeah. So luckily, those are numbers, so that
helps a little bit for figuring out what
happens first.
You usually, you start with a project that
is already containerized. So you have a Docker
file,
and
you probably also already need, like, at least
a
Kubernetes manifest,
or you can use customize or helm charts.
So that's kind of the prerequisites
to really get starting with DevSpace.
Okay. And then
yeah. So I'm just gonna kind of rephrase
this this image.
So
when you initialize a project to use with
DevSpace,
it will create a DevSpace YAML for you.
So, I mean, like,
YAML. Right? We're doing Kubernetes. So, obviously, we're
gonna have a YAML.
DevSpace, so the CLI when I say DevSpace,
I'm probably gonna refer to the the tool,
the CLI now from now on. So DevSpace
will look for the DevSpace YAML, read the
config,
and then build a
image
using whatever build tool you say it should.
It will then
push the image to the registry. Maybe you
can also say that you wanna skip pushing
to registries, and it will just build that
in memory, I believe. Then
it will check your kube conf
KubeConfig, KubeContext to understand, like, which Kubernetes cluster
should use. This is where you can, like,
use a local one or a remote one.
And then it will deploy your project to
that cluster with Helm charts or, as I
said, customize or
Kubernetes manifest.
And this is kind of the the, like,
the the basic workflow,
but then DevSpace also has this has this
dev mode that does a bunch of cool
stuff. That is where we try to
improve kind of, like, the the development cycle.
So there's stuff like hot reloading where if
you make changes in your source code,
we're not gonna
rebuild the image, and we're not gonna redeploy
the container. Instead, what we're we're gonna do
is we're gonna mount the changes directly into
the running container so you will instantly see
the changes.
It can start a
SSH server in your pod, so in your
application
that you can, like, SSH into the container
and do whatever stuff you need to do.
It can start a terminal for you automatically
through,
like, a configuration DevSpace.
And
yeah. So this is all, like, stuff that
we could, hopefully, we'll be able to explore.
Awesome. I mean, the only challenge there is
is me. So, hopefully, I don't break things
too much. Alright.
So I'm gonna try and summarize that just
to make sure that I have a a
really good mental model and understanding Yeah. Of
what DevSpace is doing. But it sounds like
I just take my existing project that I'm
working on, whether that be a monolith or
a microservice, like, whatever. I added DevSpace.YAML.
We don't know what that looks like yet,
but I'm sure we'll be right in one
of them in just a moment.
From that configuration, the DevSpace CLI is capable
of building the image using whatever tools I
already use,
optionally pushing it to a registry,
and then using my current cube context to
deploy that to a Kubernetes cluster.
And you mentioned that it has a dev
mode. We see that on the right hand
side here. And this has given us that
convenience features that we're starting to see more
and more of, which really helps us get
that sharp feedback loop for developing our applications.
Hot reloading, so important. Like, who really wants
to sit and wait for Docker image build
to work every single time they change a
bit of their code? Yeah. Exactly.
Yeah. And the local Well, guess people who
are people who are bored in an office
love when there's docker build, and you can,
like, go and have a coffee and chat
with someone for half an hour and then
come back. Or jump on a wheelchair and
have a sword fight. I don't know. Whatever
whatever your preference.
Exactly.
Okay. Okay. So hot reloading,
local host access put forward, and all the
logging that I need. And then
I haven't seen this last feature working well
on any other tool yet, so I'm very
excited.
No. I don't even know if we have
a right application to try and debug something.
But debugging, I've always I wanna
I have not even tried that debugging feature,
but I guess we'll find out.
Oh, yeah. Awesome. Okay. I'm gonna click on
initialize the project because I'm assuming this is
gonna guide
us through getting set up. Yeah. It's a
good way to get started.
I like that I can just use one
of these quick starts.
I'm gonna try and make my life a
little bit easier.
Just do Node. Js,
and then maybe we'll do we'll see how
things are going, and we we can always
try Go. But I think maybe Node. Js
is a good Sure. Point. When you think
about I was gonna dis I was gonna
discourage you from using Ruby and ASP dot
NET. That was the only thing that I
was like, maybe don't do that because I
I think there's some like, I couldn't get
them to run on my machine probably because
I have an m one.
So I think we haven't updated those yet.
Cool. Yeah. I'm not very comfortable with those
languages, so I'm quite happy to avoid them.
Alright. Let's see what we have here in
this example application.
Do I trust? Sure. Go for it.
So this
alright. So this is just an express application
that's gonna throw some HTML right down to
the browser. Yep. That's fine. Exactly. We have
a docker upload in my font. Tiny because
I was doing some other stuff today.
Yeah. Okay. That's good. Now we have a
docker file
just using node Alpine, doing a quick copy,
NPM install. It's pretty much what we'd expect.
That's pretty fair.
Yeah.
Yep. I don't see a DevSpace surprises there.
So I must remember we're gonna is that
a command for that?
Yes. Yeah. So the the quick start is,
like, just the project. So we're gonna walk
you through, like, the that that is, like,
probably what you already have, and then the
rest of it is, like, okay. Now you're
introducing DevSpace. Yeah. That's good. Like, don't make
any assumptions, which I like. So Exactly.
It's detected JavaScript.
Oh, how do I want to deploy?
Yeah. So the for the for the for
the quick start products, we do have Helm
charts that we have in a remote repository.
If you feel super
adventurous, we could try one of the others,
but then you would have to, like, actually
write them yourself, I believe.
So the easiest
is to use the Helm chart. I think
it's also in the docs. I'm not quite
sure, but I think I recently changed them
to just, like, walk you through the actual
like, what you what should you choose at
every step of the way.
Yeah.
Yeah. You have. Okay.
Well, let's start with helm. Because I If
we do the goal one, we will we
feel adventurous.
Yeah. Let's let's let's see what the hell
yeah. What this does for us with the
easy the easy start. Yeah. So we also
detect that it's a quick start project, which
makes the setup a bit more streamlined.
And then, yeah,
we want to develop because we wanna see
all the cool dev mode stuff.
Yeah. We have a Dockerfile there already.
And since you're local, I would probably suggest
skipping.
Yeah. I don't have to want to deal
with credentials that are remote.
Yeah. Okay. So we'll just avoid that for
now.
Mhmm. Alright. So this is telling us So
We can use
the namespace if we want to I'm just
gonna use default, which is my context. I
I don't think we need to worry about
that. But I
believe now we can do DevSpace dev
and
oh, yeah. Yeah. I'm okay with that. Yeah.
So there's a warning that it's like, are
you sure?
Because you might be on a shared cluster.
You might, like, be on the kind of
dev cluster when you're sharing that with other
people. So
just just wanna make sure you're not breaking
anything. Is DevSpace specifically targeted at
dev clusters and not production clusters? Or is
that something that you think it's gonna open
up to maybe production clusters? Or
You can use it for production clusters as
well as well. There's there's
another command that's DevSpace deploy, which would then
not start the dev mode, but just deploy
your
application,
like, kind of like you would in on
prod. We can check that out. And you
can use it in prod. You can use
DevSpace to do some CICD stuff for you.
Ideally, you would use DevSpace for everything, so
it really behaves the same way everywhere, and
it actually manages
your environment no matter where whether it's, like,
dev or staging or prod.
But
yeah. I mean, like, most of our users
use it for development because the dev mode
is really the thing that
stands out, I guess. I see that Oleg
said hi, which is great because Oleg is
one of the engineers at Loft. So if
we have a question, maybe he can help
us out.
Awesome. Always good to have support in the
chat.
Yeah. So I suspected I was in a
container here because my prompt changed. I typed
who am I? It says root. So, yeah,
DevSpace dev has Yeah. Spun up a container
and then put me in an interactive shell.
Uh-huh. Exactly. You are in the container right
now.
I opened the terminal for you. You can
see probably
yeah. So
there's a couple of things that
that
DevSpace does in the background, which we can
look at later in the YAML. But for
now, all you need to know is that
we are in the container now. We have
not started the web server yet.
That's why it says, like, this is how
you can work with it if you're yeah.
If you want, you can, yeah,
check out the container some more, or you
can run NPM star to see the
application.
Yeah. I just I just wanted to poke
around. I'm loving No. The sleep command. Fair
enough. Of course. This this pipeline. Like, why
not? Just Yeah.
I could see the sync thing. I assume
this is some sort of fail system. We
have an SSH server and a tunnel and
then screen.
So
yeah. Okay. Cool. But
Everything you need to
pry open the container.
So, yeah, it also automatically opens this, like,
beautiful web page and then tells you what
you could do now to try out the
functionalities
of DevSpace.
Hold on a minute. How does it open
a web page?
We can look inside the DevSpace YAML to
do it. If you're asking me how does
it happen inside
Yeah.
Like, under the hood, I don't know that.
But if you open the DevSpace YAML, there's
a there's a command for that.
But,
yeah, you would have to probably
leave the container to
check it out. But
Yeah. It does it only does it once.
Just don't know how
did that I mean, DevSpace must have detected
that a new port was opened or something.
I'm not sure.
Actually, it
pulls
I'm not a hundred a % sure, but
it does, like, a regular check on
you you provide a
URL, and it just does a regular pull
on it. And as soon as it gets
like a non 500,
I wanna say, response,
it will then open a browser and display
that page. There
you go. Okay.
Okay. So we now have a DevSpace.YAML.
We can see we've got a version and
a name.
We got something called a pipeline.
We got something called an image Yeah. Something
called a deployment.
Yeah. There's a lot of stuff happening in
there. Let's look let's look at the images
first maybe because this is kind of the
order of things.
Yeah. So we
basically say we have a bunch of images,
and this image is named app.
And then we tell it, like, okay. This
is how you have to name the image.
It can
I mean, if you wanna push it to
a registry, then this is where you would
put the
the full URL with the username and the
name of the image,
and then where to find the Docker file?
And I
think if you want to use a different
building
engine,
then you can provide that as a
property.
I would have to check the
docs myself,
which I am doing right now. Well, we
have Yeah. Can look at the or
something else. Uh-huh. Good. Even better.
Yeah. I did not even know that.
Yeah. Well, down here, I don't know. I
know it's really difficult to do that. But
it actually detects the Yeah. No. I see.
As a DevSpace YAML, which was my first
indication that I could probably all complete this.
And, yeah, looks like we
we can.
Nice. I like it when projects publish the
JSON schema, and it just works with Versus
Code because I spend most of my day
in Versus Code. So I want I want
that to be a good experience.
Makes sense.
So,
yeah, we can check deployments next. I'm gonna
explain pipelines later, but that's it's not super
important right now.
So here, we have the list of deployments
that
we can use. And, again, we have, like,
a thing named app,
and we we're just saying right now that
we're using a Helm chart. And here, we
were loading this from our
from our own repo, the Charts DevSpace SH
repo, and it's called component chart. And, like,
all the other quick starts use the same
chart.
I can probably look into it to see
what exactly gets deployed.
And then we put in some values,
namely
what the name of the image is and
which port we need to open to access
the website.
And you can use DevSpace deploy,
So the DevSpace deploy command if you only
want to deploy this without without opening the
dev mode. So you could conceivably
just run DevSpace deploy on a prod
environment and then just deploy it like it
is.
Okay.
And then I must have been this dev
key is how we hook up the
the reloading and Dev mode. Yeah.
This is the the interesting part. So we
can, like yeah. Let's run from it from
the top, I guess.
So
the basically, in dev mode, we're doing a
bunch of stuff to the container.
We're modifying it in a lot of ways.
So the first thing we need to do
is we have to, like, select the right
container or the right pod, let's say, right
container. There's a couple of ways you can
do that. You can use an image selector.
So, basically, you would select all the or
the first image
or the first container that has this that's
using this image. I think you can also
use a label selector
and probably some other ways to do that
as well.
Again, we can refer to docs later if
wanna get
excited.
This dev image in line 50, that's a
pretty cool feature.
So I said that you could deploy your
container
to production.
But then if you're developing,
you might wanna have a slightly different container,
maybe one that has, like, some kind of
DevTools installed that you wouldn't want to have
on prod. So here, we will we would
be replacing the container image with this image
that we provide a dev image,
and that's just optimized for development purposes. So
then we are not using the original image
anymore. We're using this one. And this image
also doesn't have the source code. We have
to, like, sync it to this dev container,
which we're doing in the next couple lines.
This is where the hot reloading happens as
well. We're basically saying, like, okay. I copy
everything from this path, put it into the
container.
You can also exclude things, like, for example.
This if you're using Dev Image, this is
super important. Otherwise, you just end up with
a container with nothing in it.
Okay.
Yeah. Here, we are opening a terminal,
and there's a bunch of magic happening in
DevSpace start.
We can take a look at that. I
have not yet, so I would probably be
learning something if we take a look at
that. But I actually opened it Yeah. The
all complete here because I was really hoping
to see sort of make target option
where I could just maybe because I don't
know. I don't I'm not a big fan
of arbitrary
scripts lying around and
maybe supporting some links. Yeah.
I don't yeah. Meet target would be cool
there.
Okay. Oleg, I hope you're listening. Right?
This is the feature request now.
Yeah. And then we can inject the SSH
server into the container so you can
either with your IDE or just with your
shell Right. Connect to the container.
We also for the quick start, we are
creating some proxy commands. So, basically, if you
run DevSpace or kubectl inside the container, it
will then be proxied to your host machine.
Gotta be super careful with that because everyone
who has access to the dev container could
then execute these commands on your
host machine on your local
laptop or something. Yeah.
And then we can also do some port
forwarding there.
Not quite sure what the nine two two
nine port is for.
The 3,000 is obviously for the web app.
Maybe the Node. Js will find.
That could be. I'm not sure. I I
guess Guess we could experiment with
yeah. Yeah.
And, yeah, finally, that line 72, that's that's
the thing that opens the
browser.
And as I said, so it, yeah, it
checks the status,
and then other than five zero two or
five zero three. Okay. So as soon as
usually, it's, like, as soon as the
application starts, it will then open the browser
as you've seen. So when we started the
when we run run DevSpace start, nothing happened.
But as soon as you then ran NPM
start,
that's when the web server actually got started,
and that's when the
the browser opened.
So this is the this is the cool
magic part, and the stuff that you see
here is pretty much like
the most used features in DevSpace,
which is why they're all here.
And we can talk about the others too
if you want, or we can what we
haven't tried yet is to actually change some
source code and see it just, like,
change in the browser without having to re
rebuild in everything. Yeah. That's a good idea.
I mean, we should try and see what
this kind of feedback look is like for
developers.
I'll just add that. I mean, I think
I was overcomplicating this. We could just do
command make thing. Right? Like, I don't we
don't need a special pragma for a big
target. So I'll take back my feature request.
You're okay. I like We
do have a start script.
Yeah. I think that's just for for sure
to print DevSpace,
I guess you could run migration
scripts and other things there.
And I'm gonna pull up the browser
with that local host on it.
Mhmm. Let's change
let's change some text or something. So
index dot g s.
Oh, it tells you to edit the text.
Yeah. Yeah. It tells you exactly what to
do. But you don't have to follow it.
Like, you can change other stuff if you
want to.
I mean, I am a terrible HTML and
CSS person. But, I mean, I could probably
manage to do, like,
style.
Oh.
I would have just removed the line, but
okay.
Well, we could try and make a red
background. Right?
Because this I think we're gonna find out.
I don't even know how to do background
colors. But
Okay. You just need to save the file.
You you can now check the logs if
you would like.
In any case, you have to reload the
browser to see the changes.
Oh, you have to reload. Ah. Yeah. Well
done.
Yep. That was a nightmare in the past
life, as you could tell. I know.
Yes.
I was gonna say this is not very
eye friendly, but Yeah. Okay. Well done.
We'll just go with the all black approach.
Ta da. Uh-huh.
And you see this is pretty fast, so
this this is excellent.
Yeah.
K. Cool. So I I can see how
that works. Russell's
Yeah. Has that the or Uman Russell. The
red one's not bad.
Yeah. So one of the things also is
that we need to use NodeMon
instead of running Node because,
otherwise,
we would have to restart the Node process
all the time if we make a change.
So NodeMen will detect that there was a
change, and it will kind of, like, inside
its own process, restart the node process.
Alright.
Well, that was pretty easy.
Right? Right? Okay. I think we're done now.
It's pretty good. Alright. Bye. See you soon.
Like, I can we can talk a bit
more about the other things in the DevSpace
YAML that we haven't
looked at yet? Or if you have any
specific questions, we can cover them as well.
Okay. Okay. There's a few assumptions that wanna
get out of my head. So
firstly, this terminal we're in we're in a
thing. We saw this is running screen.
I'm assuming I could just drop this, and
I actually expect this web application still. Oh,
no. It doesn't. Okay. That that ended. I
thought that was gonna run-in the background. You
stopped the process, though. Like, you stopped the
web server, so that's why it's not here
anymore. Oh, but I thought because I was
on a screen session.
I think the screen is for the I
I actually don't know. You know what? I
don't know.
Yeah. Okay. Alright. We'll just we'll just not
do that anymore.
Alright. So when I leave the when I
leave the container, it shuts all down. I
can go have my coffee, come back after
lunch, and start again. That's fine.
And then we need to run the NPM
star.
Yeah. We should be back in business. Okay.
Cool. Yeah.
And we could, for example, if you if
you didn't
ex replace
the dev
image well, if you didn't replace the image
and just use the the image that we
have, then you wouldn't need to start to
run NPM start even because then we would
use the actual production image that we built,
and that automatically starts NPM start.
But you can still, like, do the hot
reloading. That would still work. It's just that
because we're using a dev image,
it doesn't,
yeah, it doesn't use the Docker image that
we looked at.
But you said if I run DevSpace deploy
then,
that just deploy with Not quite. Not not
quite because we still need to go to
dev mode. So okay. If you open the
DevSpace YAML
Yep.
Yeah. And then we could
remove the line 50 where we just commented
out.
So now we're not replacing the dev image
anymore. We're just using the production image. You
can run DevSpace dev,
and then it would
just open the browser. And we do we
wouldn't have to run NPM start because the
entry point
okay. Interesting. The entry point would be NPM
start.
That's interesting.
What happened?
Well, I
may have broken it by running a deploy
and killing it,
and it made no oh, no. It's trying
to reach speed to red. Oh.
Oh, okay. That interesting.
I did not have that issue when I
tried it, but, yeah, if you just use
the
I guess you have to if you're doing
that, you have to probably change the image
name everywhere
because I think it's it's trying to build
the image in the images part. So if
you scroll up, there was this property called
image
and
or images. Yeah. And that that's where we
built the image.
So
I guess we could just, yeah, remove the
host name and just call it DevSpace.
Yeah. And then then change our dev image
It's or image selector.
Yeah. I don't know if we have to
change it in the deployments part as well,
but I guess we'll find out.
Oh, no. And that's trying to interesting.
Well, it's try it's still authenticating you with
Docker Hub.
Got okay.
Oh, no. It's trying to it's
trying to pull that.
Don't quite understand why it's trying to push
your image, though, because we did say that
we wanna skip.
What we can do is we can add
a property called skip push
to the app,
and that should
definitely push skip the push.
Like, when we when we say that in
the initialization
period
you know what? I actually, I don't I'm
not quite sure about that.
I thought it would be saved
somewhere.
It probably is saved somewhere because we did
skip the push initially.
We did skip that way when we ran
the init.
Yeah. And then it'll complete here, and there
is a skip push flag that wasn't set.
So I've kinda maybe that will help. I
don't know. I'm I'm Let's try. Let's try.
No. Same.
Uh-huh. Okay.
Well alright. Yeah. It seems happier now. Okay.
Yeah.
Let's see if that works because we didn't
change the image name in deployment.
So
we will see. I'm learning as well.
Yeah.
Probably need to change that in deployment as
well because that's it's still trying to deploy.
So there's in line 48. Yeah. Exactly.
Makes sense because we're telling the helm chart
that we are like, it should use this
image.
We're putting the values in there. So,
yeah,
deployment should show. I mean, this is just
Kubernetes.
I could actually run
yeah. We can see that. Yeah.
Oh, no error. Pulled image.
Which image is it trying to load? I
don't know. Maybe we should figure that out.
It's because I'm using many cube.
I will need to source.
I don't ever had to do this. It's
been so long.
The docker end because I'm actually built we'll
be building this into
computers are hard. Yeah. This this is very
interesting because I I don't
understand why we're running into this now when
it worked before.
I guess the the fact that we are
because I would have expected that we deploy
the regular like, the image that we built,
and then we
exchange the image with the dev image.
So we should have run into this problem
before,
but I might be wrong. I'm obviously wrong
because it didn't happen as I would have
thought it would.
Well, like, if you're still listening, you can
explain it. Right?
Yeah. It's it's not working.
What have I done wrong?
Control,
describe.
Oh, yes. So I was trying to pull
this image.
Which it should.
Can you check your images?
Yeah.
I think this is the right one. It
should be I mean, we're building it correctly,
apparently.
Empty. Yeah.
Yeah. I'm not sure.
Alright.
Is there a DevSpace delete
everything?
Can I will we
Yes? There's a DevSpace purge,
and that will
I don't I probably won't delete images from
your Docker registry, though, but we can Well,
it's just because we set the Docker the
Minikube Docker environment halfway through.
So now that we have that Yeah.
Although, it depends with DevSpace.
Let's try. Okay. But we do build.
It's all cached, which means I think this
image is in the right place.
It should be.
Let's try DevSpace.
Dev Let's try DevSpace.
Yeah. Okay.
I mean, as we could try DevSpace deploy
because the way that I understand it oh,
okay.
So
you broke it. It wasn't me.
Good.
I think it was just because,
yeah, the Minikube environment wasn't my local Docker
environment, and I think DevSpace was working against
my Docker desktop and not my Medikube.
And yeah. It was a weird Ah, okay.
No. Yeah. That makes sense.
But that's what's saying we have something running.
So
We have, but it doesn't do what I
was hoping it would do, which is just
start your browser immediately.
Oh, DevSpace start not found.
What
did you do?
Is is it because we're not using the
dev image anymore? So, like, this stuff isn't
No.
No. I well, because we're syncing it, so
we should be, like,
syncing everything over.
Like, literally, I tested this yesterday.
Wait a sec. Oh, yeah. Look. Waiting for
initial sync to complete, sync work, and then
Yeah. So that includes the DevSpace start. Did
you rename it or something?
I don't think so.
No. It's there.
Okay.
Okay. Bunch of stuff in this file.
We did, but not
yeah.
Because okay.
So we're we're saying open a terminal and
use the following command to start it.
I don't think our I'm not quite sure
whether our DevSpace containers have the DevSpace start
as agent. Shouldn't
in theory.
Well, I'll take it. That's probably something I've
done.
Thank you. It's not it's clearly not that
our quick start don't work properly. Alright. Let's
okay. Just to make sure that we we're
back, can you
reintroduce the dev image languages? I just wanna
make sure that
we didn't change it to the degree that
nothing works anymore.
Otherwise, we have to reset everything, I think.
Yeah. It seems okay. But Okay. That that
looks like yeah.
Okay. So if you run-in
I'm wondering if maybe you we what we
should what we would need to do is
really not open the terminal.
It's like the,
yeah, the terminal is kind of tied to
the dev image, but then
we could take a look at the documentation.
Okay. Well,
I think we can
go back to the docs and and work
through that. But I just while we're here,
right,
and then DevSpace thing,
something caught my eye, which was these commands
here. Like, I mentioned migration to earlier, not
knowing. This was set set in the DevSpace.YAML.
So it looks like there's already the ability
to run
arbitrary command. So
Yes. Is that just DevSpace
run?
Yeah. Run. Yeah. Exactly. So you could run
any kinds of
commands, anything that you need to do to,
you know, set up your development environment in
the way that you need it and then
do a DevSpace run.
Exactly.
And, yeah, it could be anything
that you would so this is why we
kind of replace Makefiles
or,
you know, like, sup supply Makefiles if you
want to. If you love your Makefiles, like,
you can still, like, do both.
If you go to back to the DevSpace
YAML, I think this is not a a
good place to talk about the pipelines.
So we scroll all the way up.
So we have these pipelines,
and this is,
like, something that we changed in in the
latest release. So we released DevSpace six, like,
a couple of weeks ago.
So we now have these pipelines that you
can completely
modify the way that you want to. There
is a default behavior for the pipelines.
I think it's
it's it's
in-depth explained in the docs, but then you
can, like, run the default behavior by just,
like, run default pipeline or something.
But, basically,
here, when you run DevSpace dev,
which is a short form for DevSpace run
pipeline dev,
this is what will happen. So you will
run all the dependencies of which we have
none currently.
You will
create the deployments.
So then that would be the the deployments
part that starts in '9 '20 '8, and
then you start the dev mode for one
or more
units. So we we named everything app here.
You could give them different names. You could,
like, say, like, all of them, or you
could just, like, have a couple. So we
could, like, have start dev app DB or
whatever you want.
And,
yeah, so similarly, in deployments, we run all
the dependencies. We build other images,
and we create the deployments.
Oh, see. So in DevSpace dev, we don't
build the images.
So if I had read this earlier. This
is why we didn't run into this issue
earlier because we don't build the images because
we're just, like, using the dev image. Got
it. Okay.
And, yeah, you could change whatever you need
here. You could add add commands. Right? Like,
here, we could you could, like, add the
migrate DB command into the dev pipeline or
the pipeline.
And then this way,
if you are someone who's, like, completely new,
just being onboarded to the team, all you
need to know know is that you have
to run DevSpace dev, and you don't need
to know, like, oh, you have to run
this script and then that, but only in
these circumstances and all of that. That's kind
of the thing that we're trying to do
here
to just give you, like, one command, and
then your development environment
is just
all shiny and perfect,
which we've seen that that works perfectly.
Awesome. Alright. No. I understand pipelines. I hadn't
really worked that out from the start when
we're looking at this. The dev and deploy
were just pipelines. I mean, I'm assuming
and I, you know, I like to make
assumptions. But if I copied Yeah.
Let's say performance test or some or performance.
Mhmm. I could just run that, like, with
DevSpace.
What was it? Pipeline
run
performance.
And this is actually Run
dash pipeline.
It's DevSpace.
Run dash.
That's one one command one dash pipeline. Yep.
Oh, nice. Okay. Cool.
I like that.
So I can start to build off and
build off all the pipelines from my application.
Because it might be that, you know, developers
just want a short feedback loop when they're
making changes to HTML, CSS, maybe some code.
But, you know, QA engineers may want to
actually run automated browser test against the and,
like, you know, maybe there's other people, machine
learning people that wanna start important data. I
don't know. Like, the I'm sure there's lots
of pipelines in a modern application these days.
Yeah. Exactly. And as it gives you the
freedom to just, like,
use the bits that you want to use,
and there's also the cool feature, which is
you can import other DevSpace YAMLs into your
DevSpace YAML. It's not showcased in this one,
but,
conceivably, you could have, like, a shared DevSpace
library with these custom commands and pipelines.
And then, you know, I wanna import that
so I can just, like,
use it without having to necessarily know
exactly.
So I could, like, define these custom functions,
custom pipelines, custom commands, and you can import
them
and
use them,
but you can also override them. So if
you have, like, some kind of testing setup
and there's some functions I wanna use, but
others I wanna just, like, do differently on
my machine or in my project, then I
can just override individual
functions or pipelines or commands. That's super cool
because you can, like, build this library of,
like, shared stuff.
Yeah. It makes a lot of sense. Like,
you know, most dev shops that I speak
to, you know,
we
we think we're in this world of polyglotism
where we are writing a Rust and Go
and Pony and C and all our app.
Like, we've got 50 different languages and 50
different services. But, really, most shops Yeah. Have
one or two languages that they really invest
in and builds up the knowledge within their
organization and within their team. And I can
see where you would want to have a
consolidation of all your DevSpace
pipelines and configuration and a central location so
that when you update that once,
every team can take advantage of that right
away with the import statement. I think that's
a really clever move. Like, that's that's a
nice feature.
Yeah. It's also new in DevSpace six. And,
really, the the goal is really that you
just you can just focus on your development.
Like, you should not be
bogged down in, oh. Like, all this knowledge
that you have to have, especially when you
start in a new place or you switch
teams or whatever,
you have to know all these, like, secret
knowledge things about, like, this this is here,
but you have to, like, press this button
first, and then you can, like, do that.
So,
yep, all this is trying to kinda cut
down on that. Do you see a future
where, you know, there's a DevSpace hub and
you have these preconfigured
DevSpaces for Go? Because I'm assuming they don't
differ lightly. And for Rust and for PHP
and for JavaScript
and Java, or do you think this is
very much Yeah. Mean organizations to
I
would
like to see that. I mean, DevSpace is
an open source project, so any way that
the community can contribute and help each other
out and make things better, share their best
practices. I think that's a good thing. I
know there was once an attempt to do,
like, something like DevSpace Cloud. I think that
was a that was the
attempt to do a share like,
a service offering, though.
Right now, most of our
customers, as I understand it, for them, it's
more like building up the internal platform,
if you will. So their focus is not
necessarily on, like, open sourcing, whatever stuff they
got going. And I guess, like,
in probably the overwhelming amount of cases, it
really is, like, very organizational specific stuff that
that you're, like,
to put in there.
I could see it. I don't think that's
where our current focus is right now,
but it would be cool. Okay. I mean,
nothing's stopping you from just creating a a
repository
and making it public because as you can
see, you can import a public Git, like,
any repository,
really. So you could just do it, put
it, you know, on GitHub, and then everyone
could pull it from from there. Yeah. That
makes sense.
Alright. There's two things on my head that
I've been kinda holding on to while we
kind of explore a little bit. So I
I wonder if you could touch on both
of those. One of them was well, one
of them is right in front of me.
Like, so I see some sort of IDE
integration. So I'll come back to that in
a second. Yes. The other thing I saw
was when we ran DevSpace,
there was a UI
command.
Is this gonna give me a Yeah. Like,
a shiny interface? Or
It's an interface. I'm not sure how shiny
it is. I mean, that that's, like, subjective,
I would say.
It oh, it's there. Yeah.
I could change my Again, is the idea
that maybe people just don't feel super comfortable
working on the CLI, so you could, like
so this is for, like, checking the logs
of your containers and, like, not managing your
containers, but being able to debug them and,
like, try things out in them.
Like, my honest personal opinion is that it
could do more. Right now, it's just kind
of like
yeah. Just like a yeah. A little bit
shinier version of what you could also get
from the CLI.
I think it could it
could be much better. Right? I think there's,
like like
as I mentioned before, and I would like
to look at that maybe at some
point later as well as, like, you can
have the you can define dependencies.
So if you have a
an application that depends on, like, a microservice
that depends on other microservices, you can define
that. And I would really like to see,
like, a dependency tree, a visual one.
Right? I think that would be a super
cool feature. Again, Oleg, if you're listening, please
put that in the feature
backlog.
Because I think that is something that I've
heard from a lot of people while when
I was, like, you know, I was a
consultant for a long time where people were
just like, I don't I just wanna know
what my applications depend on and which,
like, what what the actual, like, tree is.
Yeah. I think that would be cool. But
right now, it's just, like, looking at logs,
looking at stacks.
K. Cool. Yeah. I guess you can run
commands from there as well. Alright.
Well And the other thing I've seen then
was the Versus Code integration. I'm curious what
what this adds.
You this is super cool. So I highly
recommend to check out the example project.
And what it will do is it will
open that SSH server,
and then it will open your Versus Code
if you have remote
like,
this this remote SSH extension.
If you have that installed, it will then
open Versus Code, which is directly connected to
the container,
and that is really awesome.
Okay.
I mean, I'm just gonna go with default
namespace.
Yeah. Yes. I'm sure.
Oh, let's see.
Yeah. That's just a bit of a walk
through for you to see what's happening. Ah,
okay.
So we're just waiting for the containers to
come up right now. We're just just waiting
for the yeah.
So that's just gonna spin up a Versus
code for me.
Or just a Versus code with remote.
Alright. Okay. Yeah. As long as you oh,
as long as you have the Versus code
CLI because it's starting it from the shell.
So I'm not sure if you have that,
though. Yeah. But it's it's failing. It says
I can't drag it on. Okay. Now yeah.
Can't read it. What does it say?
Oh, no. It's not over here.
I I couldn't read the error message. What
did it say?
It said it couldn't connect to the remote,
but I don't know why.
Alright.
Are you willing to share what's in your
EDC host? Because I think I had a
problem earlier.
And,
like, an older version of DevSpace,
the we did some stuff there, and then
you had to remove that so it works
now.
I'm just looking for the
for the Slack exchange where I got had
that explained
to me.
Okay.
So because in your e oh, no. In
the SSH config, it wasn't in the e
t c host. Sorry. There should be, like,
an entry for this
quick start stuff.
Ah.
Yeah.
Okay. So there's
my app DevSpace.
And,
actually, that
looks
right because what we should
want to see is
So the quick start,
that's
right. I don't know if, like, my app
is that the
okay.
Do you still get that error, by the
way? I'm I'm assuming you have that on
another.
I I removed the old one. Let's try
again.
Yeah.
And this is some great user research right
now.
Could not establish connection to my app dot
DevSpace.
Can you try to just SSH to my
app dot DevSpace
without the,
you know, Versus code? Yeah. That doesn't work
either.
Oh. Bad configuration option DevSpace.
Interesting.
I guess, like, comment.
Oh, no. It's not running.
Wait. But this is not even the right
port.
Oh, we have ten
six three seven.
I think the other one is probably oh,
can we just remove the other one here,
the the one above?
The one above.
Yes.
I think that's like a magic comment, isn't
it? I'm gonna leave that.
I think it's being used to parse and
add stuff to that fail. So I've probably
been breaking this demo because of that.
Yeah. Let let's just again say that this
is something you broke and clearly not
some weird behavior that we haven't anticipated.
No. It failed. No
matching keys. I'm just going to
okay. Then instead, let's look at the DevSpace
YAML to see what it should do. I
know why that's not working.
Oh, you know? My SSH sock is hooked
up to one password, and you're probably adding
them to a different agent.
DevSpace will be adding it to the default
SSH agent, so I don't think it's gonna
work. Yeah. Probably. Okay. Well, then let's still
look at the DevSpace YAML. And
if you at home try it out yourself,
and you don't have this weird setup with
the SSH cable work.
Because, again, I tried it out yesterday, so
it should still be working.
Oh, this is the wrong DevSpace. We need
to go to the
v
Versus Code example DevSpace exactly.
Yeah. Right. So,
yeah, if you scroll down a little bit
this is very similar to what we just
saw.
So in the
sync
part
Yep. Yeah. We're just, like, doing some Git
magic
stuff there. I think it's in the pipeline
in the dev pipeline, probably, what's happening, the
the interesting part, I'm guessing. So scroll down
a little bit. Oh, yeah. There it is.
So we run the default pipeline of dev,
which is pretty much what we saw, so
deploying stuff.
And then we this is just one command.
Right? We because the SSH
server has been created in the SSH part,
what we can do here is we just
start
Versus Code with the code code command
and then basically say, like, the the folder
that you should open
is
this,
like, remote
container
that you can connect to through SSH
remote.
Not quite sure how the Versus Code remote
thing works, but it seems like this is
just a a URL that you can just
feed into the code
Nice.
Command.
So this would be super cool if it
were.
Yeah. That's my fault, I think, just because
of my weird setup.
Yeah. But, like, this
again, if you if you just wanna try
it out at home,
I'm sure if there is a CLI for,
like, intelligent or something that would allow you
to similarly just, like, open a remote
folder, you could probably do that as well
here.
And, yes, really convenient.
I'm I'm guessing there's probably other stuff that
we can also do with Versus Code, but
I haven't checked that yet.
Alright. Well, we have a few comments.
So, apparently, I'm the ultimate product tester
because
on every hands on session, I managed to
break something.
Yeah. Thank you. Well, you're not breaking something.
That's the thing. You just have a very
particular setup, which is good to know. I
mean, we're probably not gonna fix it because
it doesn't work for you because you're, like,
one of the 00.1%
of people who do it the way that
you do, possibly.
Yeah.
Yeah. I spent too much time playing with
myself. But if I just left it alone,
maybe more stuff would work. I think I
definitely am the the lowest common denominator here.
But You you pretty much know what you're
doing, which is, like, not necessarily I mean,
I'm not gonna say that our users don't
know what they're doing, but
that's obviously, we're targeting people who
might not know exactly
all the ins and outs
about, like, you know, SSH connections or networking
or, like, how to set up stuff in
Kubernetes.
So,
yeah, we're focusing on on the group of
people who just, like, do the standard stuff
more than, like,
very specific edge cases, which is, like, probably
what most companies are doing.
Okay.
We also have a question from Russell who
is saying
it's went off the screen, but I'll read
this one out. Is there any support for
multiple copies?
So this is where Russell is assuming there's
a shared development cluster that is being used
by multiple people, and they may want to
work on the same service at the same
time. So I guess the DevSpace.YAML
would be the same. How would that work?
Yeah. So this is where you could use
dependencies,
for example. So let's say we're we're the
two of us are working on
different
services that depend on each other. We can
I can define your service as a dependency,
and you can define my service as a
dependency?
And then on the cluster,
there is it's either a config map or
a secret. I'm not quite sure about that,
but it's saved on the cluster.
And DevSpace will see, oh, there is a
instance of this dependency running, so I don't
need to deploy it. I'm just gonna use
this instance here as a dependency for my
microservice.
And if you change something, it will be
reflected in my microservice because I'm using your
dependency.
So as long as we're on the same
cluster, this will work out of the box,
which is pretty awesome.
But I guess if someone if two people
wanted to work on the same service, they
would have to use different namespaces to make
sure that would work and doesn't
Yeah. But that is not and I don't
think it should work, honestly. I I think
if two people work on the same class
and the same product at the same time,
it's it's just generally not a good idea.
Yeah. Use namespaces. Keep them separate, I guess.
Yeah. Yeah. Or vClusters,
which is another product that we develop.
Yeah. Yeah. We've done a session on vCluster,
but it has been a long time. So
I'll need to reach out to you to
you and Yeah. And Retch and get something
else on the couch for that because it'd
be good to see what's going on vCluster.
But that that's not what we're doing today.
Alright. So I really like this. You know,
DevSpace gives me something I could put into
GET, which is, the step one for all
tools. If if I'm gonna use it, I
have to be able to store the config
in GET. We have a YAML definition for
describing how to build
and
ship
our application,
and it sets up all of that plumbing
that just gives us this interactive environment report
forward and and potential
debugger,
which I'm not fancying my chances of my
my machine getting to work. So
As I said, I also haven't used the
debugger feature, so I couldn't even help you
troubleshoot it probably.
Well, no. But, you know, we're I think
what we've done is we're able to show
people that this tool is best, how to
get started,
and, you know, how it could be adapted
to different languages and such. Now I I
like that the documentation kind of has I
mean, these are all pretty popular languages, Node,
Python, Java, Ruby, Go language, PNSB. So, you
know, people should go check it out and
let us know how you get on. Feel
free to leave comments or reach out to
either of us directly on Twitter. And it's
always fun to share. Yeah. Is there anything
else that we could do with comfort?
I think the I mean, there's, like, this
function sections,
which is, like, a way that you can
define, like, your own custom functions,
but I think this is like, I don't
know how interesting this is. This is just
another thing that you can define.
I do wanna
just give people the chance. If you if
you have more in-depth questions, especially, like, more
technical questions, we have a public Slack, which
is you can see that on the top
right,
and you can join that Slack and ask
you questions.
And, you know, like, if you have any
feature requests, maybe just drop them in there.
We have some lovely engineers there who will
help you out.
Yeah. Apart from that, I think we covered
most of it.
Most of the, like, standard stuff. If you
wanna do something more specific, the docs will
hopefully help you.
If you want to contribute,
as I said, it's open source, so feel
free to check out the GitHub
repository.
And, you know, even if you're just changing
a typo in the docs, that's also helpful.
So feel free to just, like,
you know, send in some pull requests or
something.
Thanks, Russ. Have a great weekend too.
Well, I mean, we've taken a good look
at what DevSpace offers.
I hope that people's interest has peaked and
they go kick the tires on it. But
maybe you could share
you know, I I didn't realize it was
on DevSpace six, but I'm assuming the market
is ongoing and continue to improve. Like, what's
on the road map for DevSpace? What are
you working on next?
Then you're literally asking the wrong person for
that. I
do not do not know. Stuff and things.
That's all I have to say. Yeah. Lots
of cool stuff. Lots of good things. Just
Oh, yeah. We're we're gonna make it even
better. We're gonna make it work on Rawkode's
computer.
Alright. Awesome.
Well, I think that's us then. I'm looking
forward to catching up with you in Edinburgh,
a cute puddle. And so I will see
you then. Super excited. Lots of karaoke.
I hope everyone has a great weekend. I
hope you have a great weekend. Any last
words before I say goodbye?
Just, you know, be kind to each other,
and thanks for having me. Awesome. Thank you.
Alright. Have a wonderful weekend. We'll see you
all soon, and bye bye.